[Music]
[Music]
hey guys ins ver ever going to talk
about the inter Garen's fate in the
final season supportive it is there's
trailers and of course a few leaked
photos curling Danny accompany me John
is heading to Winterfell with her all
remaining dragon tsunamis not to conquer
it but rather to save it from the net
King and his army of the Dead Danny and
John are sailing towards bike harbor the
main support of the north William solid
once they arrive over daredevil me to
track you on the kingsroad and then
right together to Winterfell most of
this will probably take place off screen
and will only see them approaching and
entering Winterfell and the trailer
provided that shot I assume this season
eight official photo is them looking at
Minard fell from a distance some believe
this is somewhere beyond the wall
judging from the landscape behind them
but remember winter is here and the net
gains closer to them than ever before so
it could be anywhere but my guess is
it's somewhere close to Winterfell this
photo which was released separately from
the other season 8 photos likely the
pigs the same scene between John and
Danny but from a different angle we've
already known for quite some time that
John and Danny will arrive in FL in very
first of the final season in a callback
to the serious very first episode of the
first season with Daniel cam standing in
for King Robert at his so then he
arrives the Winterfell with John in the
cruise the John that introduces her to
his family
you know photo ops is a tense meeting
between Danny and Sansa but she first
found out from the first official game
of Thrones Season a teaser posted by
Entertainment Weekly they shared the
entire season 8 cover story online when
she closed a detail description of the
opening scene there it says that since I
said not to be thrilled that John
Bettany to his new fancy Targaryen
girlfriend at least not at first
and so what they meant by that when
Demetrios released a short clip of that
very meeting since it does save NFL is
your story's the same liner father said
to King Robert and here I the mean FL
but by senses face expression we can see
she doesn't like any of that however
even though the post states that sense
is not real with John bending the knee
to Danny did you notice how it says
senses not thrilled that John Bethany to
Danny or at least not at first
then is not heading north to conquer the
north but rather to save it and that
something the northern Lords will see
for themselves in the very beginning of
the final season
however this will not be Danny's only
tense first meeting as beside the lady
of NFL she is also going to meet
Justin's best friend senator Lee whose
father and brother she burned alive
during this past season
many argue Sam will not care about it
and truth be told he probably will not
more and much about his father but he
will care about his brother
hopefully same understands that Danny
did not have a choice his father and
brother the reason why one of Danny's
biggest allies is gone now olena Terrell
and Danny still gave them an opportunity
to been Denis which they refused then he
did not have a choice so yes there will
be some tension between Danny and Senza
as well as between Danny and Sam until
they see for themselves who the initial
is and what her true intentions are
however there will probably be no
intense moments between aria in any in
fact I think that Danny an aria will get
along very well considering how both of
them admire and respect strong and
powerful women
also since are especially at about again
history and agency Aegon riding sister
wives has seen in season two bit with
Zane a Targaryen being her harine we can
imagine she is predisposed to like and
be fascinated by Danny and her dragons
in season eight which this clip seems to
be suggesting everyone is in fear of
such beasts flying a button but Arya
Stark is happy to finally see one after
greeting John's family then he will
likely receive shocking news about a
dragon this area in the shot we have
Danny at the courtyard of NFL which is
from the season 8 premiere every know
it's rare meeting all the Starks since
then is in the ground level of NFL
quarter then looking down and she's a
little obsession likely listening to
Brennan's wheelchair was telling her
about the wall the night King game is
Arian brain basically airs the news that
the night King used the dragon to bring
the wall down and it will not be longer
until they're here as we all know Danny
know she lost the dragon but she did not
know the night King reanimated him it
will basically fight any in the future
so this is definitely coming as a huge
shock to the dragon queen from this
promotion photo we received a few days
ago we know for a fact that brain will
be welcoming Justin and Dan in the
quarter just like everyone else
what full of snacks for Danny is an
urgent meeting a meaner fellow a
majority of the north lords and the
north sell ice at the Great Hall in
order to discuss their strategy and
offenses against the night king almost
all the main characters will be there
which we got to see from the first
season eight photos we got the sadawa
cents a day
breanne I make a mistake almost all main
characters so the serious will be there
as well most likely including Jamie from
the new teaser she also know Tyrion will
attend these meetings as well which
again is not coming as a surprise as it
was expected the northerners who not
accept her as good as John did it has
been officially confirmed for quite a
long time ago that since then Dana will
have a very tense first meeting and it
was also recently confirmed that Tyra
note from Lord suicide with Sansa and
shared the same feelings towards the
Dragon Queen the note nerds will need
some convincing to trust Danny
according to Bella Ramsay her character
Lina Mormont is not very happy with the
arrival of a foreign Queen so it's not
only sense that who'll give some hard
time to Jon over Danny but it's also of
the note lords and ladies and this right
here is the first meeting summoned by
Jon Snow upon their arrival at
Winterfell
since the northerners did not accept any
very well Tyrion is pretty much saying
they might not like each other but they
must fight together nonetheless rather
wise they will all die this speech
should bring the northerners to their
senses one of the most important events
of season regarding the queen of dragons
will surely be her pregnancy in her
eventual marriage with Jon Snow while
finding out the truth about Jon's
parentage is also important to highlight
as one of the season's biggest events
with John Denny brain and Sam being at
the same place as early as of season 8
premiere it's fair to assume that either
those two same or brain will reveal the
truth about Joshua haired edge to Jon
and even possibly to Danny too early on
in the season obviously this revelation
of Danny being John's and will come as a
huge shock to both of them and will most
certainly change their relationship
therefore many of you are probably
wondering why would they marry chatter
upon finding out they're in fact related
I already made an entire video regarding
this topic but it some of you have not
seen it lemme introduce with a Targaryen
varying theory of mine with a few
sentences yes even though they will at
this point be aware of their family ties
John intend evil marry but no they will
not marry just because of love nor
because they want to seal their lines
they will do it because of their child
John and Danny might or might not
continue their intimate relationship
after they found out the truth but I
don't have to because Danny already got
pregnant in the season 7 finale
long story short even though both of
them will without a doubt refuse to even
think about marriage whether it's
political or other WOD in the beginning
of the season upon learning that they're
related
they'll hear even strong reasons to do
so
in the season and the reason is going to
be Danny's pregnancy John has been a
bastard son his entire life and he most
certainly will not allow his child to be
born out of wedlock and live a life he's
been living nor would anyone that life
for her child not only would it put
their child in a pretty bad situation
but House Targaryen could not be
continued if they don't marry and make
the child legitimate so Targaryen
vetting is most likely happening later
on in the final season that's the only
way for their child to be legitimate to
be a Targaryen and the only way for
House Targaryen to not become extinct
after John and Danny's death
so in the first two episodes before the
battle for Winterfell Danny will have
all this first meeting Tsarevich that
will be quite intense then it will also
probably teach John how to ride a dragon
which was Candide by trailer in teasers
in the trailer VC John and Danny
approaching Jokinen regal and they're
probably flying them above NFL and this
is a reaction of various Davos in Tyrion
seeing it remember that all these three
have already seen dragons about their
heads quite a lot of times so the only
reason they would look at a dragon with
a bit of shark would be seeing just on
riding day an insider Jagan Rago a
gherkin named after John's father
Rhaegar Targaryen
then comes the already infamous third
episode of the final season the battle
for vena fell then he will have all our
armies defend Winterfell with your a
commanding her forces as we all know
this battle for ven FL will be a huge
defeat for the living and then it will
lose quite a bit over army during this
battle click photos confirmed she will
lose most of the Trekkie who will then
be reanimated by the White Walkers
most of the unsullied will probably meet
her end as well for quite a long time we
have been wondering where the Jen Queen
and Jocelyn will retreat with their
crews the remaining armies Saturday
loose Vina fell some thought it would be
hairy I personally thought it will be
King's Landing but recently release
teaser has proven us all wrong
as it provided a clip from episode 4
where John and Danny are at Dragonstone
looking into details of the fireplace
especially looking at props the stone
curves and the metalwork we noticed that
it's the same thing we already saw a
gemstone so now we know they will
retrieve the gemstone after Winterfell
Falls looks like John and Danny will
have a tense conversation after losing
battle for Venna fell and since they are
at gemstone this clip is likely from
episode 4 and is the post-fight moment
but also seemingly the pole Joshua
parentage reveal moment as well
this does not necessarily mean that the
entire living side will seek shelter at
the ancestral state of House Targaryen
and make gemstone the place where they
will meet their next stand against night
King it is possible that only Danny and
a handful of her protectors will stay a
gemstone until Danny gives birth to her
child while everyone else led by John
Snow will make their final stand at
King's Landing many possibilities here
but one thing is certain then will be a
gemstone in episode 4
regarding the his endgame there's no
confirmation yet and therefore nothing
can be said for sure
both the John and Danny are tied to the
other high prophecy which includes the
historic legend of a heroes sacrificing
his love in order to save the world from
the long night well son she already told
Danny - she has a role to play in the
prophecy as does Jon Snow so that might
be one of the possible end games for
Danny it's also going to be interesting
to see how her pregnancy will play out
as well no Danny's mother died giving
birth to her and even John sentience
matters died giving birth to them as
well hopefully both Danny and her child
survived it so we pretty much know
everything regarding Dana's fate in the
first 4 episodes of the final season in
episode 1 she'll arrive at Winterfell
where she's going to meet John's family
and face many times first meetings in
episode 1 or 2 Danny Blair she's
pregnant with John child and not long
after this you'll also learn about
Joshua lineage summer in there Danny
will also teach John how to ride the
dragon in episode 3 Dan in her army
sulfide the Starks ancestral home
against the night King but after it
falls she will retreat with others to
Dragonstone in episode 4 whether she'll
stay there and for how long is unknown
perhaps she stays there to give birth to
her child while John finds night King
which would be very similar to how
John's murdered lien as stated the Tower
of joy other has been Rhaegar fought on
the Trident their heavy guys everything
we know about the giant Queens fate in
season 8 and I have to admit it's quite
a lot sure we do not know Danny's
endgame yet but we pretty much know
everything else I hope you liked this
video and please let me know your
thoughts about all of this in the
comment section down below and as always
I hope you guys enjoyed this video if
you did please make sure to subscribe to
our Channel and they hope to see you in
the next one peace